AI can is an opportunity to bring our
researchers together from across the AI
institutes and really across the country
to share their ideas to get to know each
other and to look for new opportunities
for collaboration my name is Nikola Papo
I an assistant professor at the
University of Toronto and a Canada CI
chair at the vector Institute my
research group studies the security and
privacy of machine learning which is
essentially trying to get us to a point
where we as end users as a society we
can trust AI systems to make predictions
that are correct and also to make these
predictions without relying too much on
sensitive data my name is goldish pady
and I'm assistant professor at Mel
University I have adun position at the
University of Montreal a core academic
membership at Mila and one of the CI
chairholders from 2017 I started working
on this new field which called
algorithmic fairness the goal is just
like people are realizing that like just
focusing on one aspect which is just the
performance should not be enough so like
we should also think about the different
biases in the systems like we for
different demographics for example for
female versus male maybe the results of
the models are different so maybe you
want to do something about it and that's
kind of like the question I started
thinking about like can we actually
trust the systems we decided to hold AI
can this year in St John's at the advice
of our national program committee this
is a group of chairs who helps us to
plan our event EV and activities so that
they really meet the needs and the
desires of the Canada sear AI chairs
Community the Canada C AI chairs are
really some of the top AI researchers in
the world they are more than 120 now
researchers that we have either
attracted or kept in Canada through this
program we're really taking the time to
reflect together as a group what we're
trying to achieve as a community of
researchers working on the ey in Canada
having the chairs together to talk about
our responsibilities as researchers to
deliver AI that is delivering positive
social impact for society where is it
that we as researchers can work together
to help to inform and guide policy how
can we work with our partners in
different sectors in the government to
make sure that Canada is developing AI
that is really delivering positive
social
[Music]
benefits